non mais il est obsédé par la religion
en fait il pose des questions qui ne se
posent pas il crée des problèmes là il y
en a pas c'est les jours fériés ça fait
des centaines d'années qui qui existent
ils sont dans le patrimoine de la France
dans l'histoire de la France et tout le
monde en profite là il fait comme si
avec eux les catholiques qui étaient
considérés en France mais tout le monde
en profite en réalité c'est très bien et
je pense que ça ne dérange aucun Juif
aucun musulman que ces jours fériés
fassent référence à des fêtes
catholiques donc c'est de la démagogie
complète et c'est déjà lui qui avait
fait une loi sur le burkini donc il est
obsédé par le la religion il fait que ça
pour faire du buzz et même mieux tu as
raison parce que en 2004 vous savez la
fameuse loi sur la laïcité à l'école et
ben il est il est prévu dans cette loi
que les élèves qui sont pas de
confession catholique ou protestante et
ben ils peuvent aussi demander
à peu près ça fait à peu près trois fois
par an bah eux aussi une fête pour leur
religion il y a cinq religions qui sont
concernées sur le sujet donc voilà donc
il y a aucun problème en fait
il y a un problème
laissez-le parler s'il vous plaît moi je
trouve qu'il a raison parce que je ne
suis pas pour supprimer les fêtes
religieuses catholiques mais si on ne
les supprime pas je suis pour que l'on
introduise des jours fériés pour les
fêtes juives et les fêtes musulmanes
notamment par exemple
on a le droit non on a le droit de
s'absenter mais ce ne sont pas des jours
fériés par exemple que le le fin du
ramadan devient un jour férié que
l'effet de Juifs deviennent des jours
mais pourquoi est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que vous comprenez ce qu'il dit
ou est-ce que vous êtes prêts sont
démagogie dites la vérité parce que là
moi voilà moi je fais Kippour je suis
désolé je demande tu dis n'importe quoi
non non pas du tout pour les élèves qui
souhaitent le demander qu'ils ont été
catholiques doivent l'être et pas les
autres légions
quand il dit des centaines d'années
c'est pas vrai c'est Napoléon s'il te
plaît
tradition catholique ça ne me pose aucun
problème d'être dans ce pays de
tradition catholique qui qui continue à
faire ça et justement pour introduire
cette modernité dont tu parles et pour
dire que il y a aussi de l'altérité et
qu'il y a d'autres religions que la
religion catholique ou protestante il a
été introduit en 2004 cette possibilité
si tu as un élève musulman tu peux
demander si tu es un élève juste tu peux
demander un élève arménien tu peux
demander si tu es un élève bouddhiste tu
peux demander où est le problème donc
tout le monde est reconnu
n'importe quoi les gens n'en peuvent
plus voilà une amie que la France et
judéo-chrétienne le Gilles la le
calendrier a été créé par le pape Grégor
Grégoire 13
soit férié
en 2004 et voilà mais arrête de dire des
bêtises sinon tu fais tu m'as dit tu
fais toutes les fêtes mais c'est tous
les jours fériés et dis pas de bêtises
mais arrête de dire des bêtises mais
arrête
juifs dans l'année si je devais pas
venir moi tout le temps
tu peux dire de telles conneries je
comprends pourquoi Fatou elle se barre
au Sénégal
c'est pas possible mais qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte
[Applaudissements]
non mais franchement tu sais comment
elle fait juif tu veux que je te dise
dites moi
c'est férié tout le temps mais tu te
rends compte des bêtises que tu racontes
pourquoi mais est-ce que tu te rends
compte des bêtises que tu racontes non
bêtise que tu dis ça veut dire déjà 7
ans tu fais toutes les fêtes juives au
frérot tu as 4 jours dans l'année
donne-moi donc tous les tout le monde va
faire toutes les fêtes juives en
septembre ils vont venir travailler 4
jours parce que Gilles Verdez mes frérot
allez retourne voir tes amis là il y a
que des amis il y a que des gens qui
regardez pour se poser ce genre de
question je n'ai jamais vu un musulman
ou un juifs
mais du coup ce genre de débat ça fout
la merde ça oppose les gens je suis pas
d'accord
alors que toi tu vas en rajouter
justement il veut supprimer des feutres
religieuses pour mettre par exemple des
des jours fériés sur des dates
importantes pour les droits de la femme
les droits des LGBT donc des choses
civiles comme ça mais faut pas être dupe
faut pas être libre ce sont les mêmes ce
sont ses amis le Tour de France les
sapins les amis les crêpes et tout ce
qui avait dit les Français tout ce qu'il
fait maintenant une entreprise de
déconstruction de l'atéro excusez-moi
parce que lui il ne demande pas qu'on
mette Pessah
c'est n'importe quoi
tu travailles les jours fériés pendant
15 jours pour tout le monde les mecs
savent même pas pourquoi ils font ça
faisait manger des galettes aussi espèce
de quoi
il faut arrêter de bousculer quand même
les française et auxquelles les Français
sont attachés d'ailleurs même si c'est
un calendrier au calendrier attaché
c'est notre histoire notre culture il
faut arrêter maintenant sans arrêt de
sortir des conneries bien sûr cela dit
les spécialistes à Monsieur Piol le
maire de Grenoble c'est pas comme s'il y
avait que les catholiques qui en
profiter tout le monde en profite et
c'est normal il y a plein de gens alors
évidemment les catholiques pensent à
cette fête religieuse mais il y a plein
de gens qui n'y pensent même plus c'est
dans notre culture c'est dans notre
traditions donc pourquoi vouloir tout
changer systématiquement c'est
insupportable non mais c'est incroyable
non c'est bon bon allez vas-y il faut il
faut rappeler quand même je peux plus
moi aimer il faut rappeler que tu dois
rentrer chez toi
que ça suggestion vient après le fichier
potentiel de jeunes qui ont fait l'Aïd
et le ministère de l'Intérieur le
renseignement intérieur a demandé à
certaines académies de lister le nombre
d'élèves absents pour l'Aïd donc tout
n'est pas si simple on a le droit
peut-être mais tout n'est pas si simple
on va lire notre monde idéal n'existe
pas le fait de supprimer ça de supprimer
toutes les fêtes religieuses ça
empêcherait un fichier bien sûr pas du
tout
ils ont donné une solution tu vois tu
vois pas que c'est c'est la France qui
recule
c'est la France il était toute la ville
en
mais sans rigoler tu as des idées des
années des dates à toutes les idées qui
ont foiré mais qui font qu'aujourd'hui
euh tu vois bien ce qui se passe en fait
tu étais une fois voilà toi tu as des
choses vraiment personnel Gilles tu fais
quoi comme fête parce que il fait tout
lui parce qu'il veut pas travailler vous
pouvez tous les rappeler papa mais c'est
vrai moi ça dépend comme ça
et en gros non mais c'est vrai voilà il
rencontre une musulmane il s'appelle
Souleyman tu connais pas lui il a rien à
[__] lui du moment qu'il veut juste
pécho lui je connais celui-là c'est un
rat mort oui alors moi je dis que ça
peut toucher à l'histoire et elle est
comme ça et c'est tout faut pas toucher
à Noël faut pas toucher Pâques déjà ils
nous ont enlevé le lundi de Pentecôte
ils ont dit que c'était pour les
personnes âgées c'est bon on donne ses
cadeaux il faut arrêter il faut pas
toucher à ça et c'est pas c'est pas la
première fois qu'il fait aujourd'hui
on le connaîtrait pas aujourd'hui on le
connaît donc voilà donc il a viré quand
même il a quand même réussi son coup euh
qu'est-ce qu'il veut moi je veux rien je
dis simplement que il faut faire
attention à ne pas écarter les gens
d'autre religions et que la religion
je vais te demander un truc avec moi
arrête
de taper sur les chrétiens
je fais plusieurs fois non et ça sache
de supporte pas moi je te dis ouais je
te le dis si pas des moyens on dirait
que arrête avec ça arrête arrête avec
quoi non mais je te le dis arrête arrête
avec ça arrête et demain je dis pensons
aux autres religions
est-ce que vous vous sentez empêcher de
fêter par exemple qui pour en France
est-ce que est-ce que tu te sens empêché
de faire le ramadan en France
je n'aime pas du tout voilà
est-ce que tu te sens empêché d'écouter
on est d'accord carrément tu dis mais
c'est pas possible sans rigoler c'est
pas possible mais moi je trouve que
c'est pas possible arrête un peu non
mais sérieux plutôt que
toutes tes idées toutes tes idées en
l'occurrence c'est pas les miennes
elles sont pires toutes tes idées moi
j'aime bien le c'est le mur voilà c'est
le mur tu le vois le mur tu le vois le
mur pourquoi tu vas le prendre pourquoi
est-ce que l'on essaie pas
on a essayé bien sûr
politiquement maintenant si on peut
envisager éventuellement ça a été évoqué
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure l'Aïd
pourquoi pas ayant toujours pourquoi pas
mais rajouter pas enlever il y a 7 fois
la nouvelle anchois
tout le monde après ces nouvelles en
chinois c'est tout après
3 jours
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on a toujours qui vont se plaindre 2004
en plus de la religion catholique au
protestante il y a 5 cultes
supplémentaires il y a les confessions
arméniennes bouddhistes juives
musulmanes et orthodoxe
fériés pour toutes ces religions et ça
sera très important
c'est déjà un premier temps
la commission c'est la commission
statique avait été créée en 2003 qui a
réfléchi de manière extrêmement
intelligente
nous casse les couilles
moi je suis chrétienne merde il respecte
r se con merci de Sylvie voilà qui
m'envoie ça et c'est vrai arrête arrête
mais on t'adore heureusement que tu es
là parce que c'est vrai que si on avait
pas un
casse-couilles comme toi
on va voir si un sondage tiens sondage
voilà bah qui perdait
5 %